shania that looks like the most
comfortable spot
ever no just like
i'm sitting on a cloud of cushions it's
awesome to surround my photos it's good
to see you look great and
this is what a fantastic reason to be
chatting today the 50th anniversary of
the juno awards what an amazing time
right i can't believe it yeah it's been
it's been a long time that's for sure 50
years
something definitely we're celebrating
and you're going to be up there with
i mean the lineup of people that's going
to be celebrating is fantastic just
canadian icons left right and center
including yourself what does it feel
like
to be able to say that you're going to
be celebrating the 50th with all of
these people that are
um that are they're huge legends in uh
in canadian music
i mean it's a it's a giant honor and
um you know i'm just always thrilled to
be among my fellow canadians
and so proud that we have
so many like you said
you know legendary iconic canadians that
have
that are known all around the world so
it's just really good to bring it all
home
and recognize each other and support
each other
so i'm really thrilled because i'm going
to be presenting an award so it's
especially exciting for me with all of
your experience
up on stage are there any nerves that
are involved in
doing something like presenting an award
i think there's i think i could i would
say that there's always
an adrenaline before you you know
get in front of the camera or walk out
on a stage i think that it's
and sometimes i think it's hard to
determine whether it's nerves
excitement adrenaline um
whatever it is it
it's fun and it's um
i would say excitement's a really good
word for it and i'm hyperactive anyway
so
after genuine on to that and and more
excitement
or and a bit of nerves it's a
it's it can get over the top you know in
in the excitement level but it's a lot
of fun
yes that excitement is it is it the same
has it been consistent
over your years i mean 1994 is when you
won your
your first juno do you have a a very
vivid memory
of that particular event
you know i just remember thinking
here we go this is what it feels like
and you know i've been watching the
junos
my whole childhood
so um
[Music]
it was just one of those moments of wow
i can't believe i'm really here
and here we go this is for real
it's it's um an incredible moment for
anyone that has an opportunity to be in
that spot
do you do you remember what you felt and
what you were thinking when they called
your name
well i was i was quite emotional
because my parents weren't there to see
the moment and to share the moment i
that was probably you know
it was difficult to
not difficult to enjoy it i was happy
but it was
it was a mixed feeling kind of moment
where
i instantly thought wow i wish my
parents could see this
and and could you know join in on the
moment and feel the joy with me
but so it was kind of one of those mixed
emotions feeling in that regard but
of course i was just really proud and
um
overwhelmed in a great you know in a
beautiful way
well as far as mixed emotions go i don't
think your fans have any mixed emotions
about you
returning to vegas in december heading
back to the zappos theater what are you
feeling right now how are you feeling
about it
i'm i'm i'm impatient
and then patient but um
you know just building up a lot of
anticipation and excitement
so i think that when we all get together
again it's going to be
the only thing i can think of is
explosive you know it's just
it the energy and the excitement builds
up so
um it'll just be time to celebrate and
let loose and go nuts i mean i think
that's
that's definitely what i'm gonna do you
know we're talking a lot about the
excitement and anticipation of
of getting out on stage for different
things but this is a special thing
you know the idea that people can be
back together again and you're going to
be there
with all massive numbers of your fans
finally being able to celebrate together
are you anticipating the kind of
excitement that it's going to be like
for them and for you i can
i'm feeling it myself already so
i think it's just really one of those
moments or it's going to be one of those
moments where
it's christmas eve or it's the day
before your birthday and you
you can't sleep and you're
uh really just over the top of
excitement and energy
and once we all get together
i mean it may it may be quite emotional
as well i mean i keep talking about the
excitement and everything and it will be
but
it'll be a bonding experience i think
because
you know on my last show in vegas in
march
it's we all i mean we didn't even get a
chance to say goodbye nobody knew that
that was going to be it for
so long so now that we're all going to
be getting back together again
crew dancers uh you know
the band the fans
none of us realized that we would be
separated for so long like literally
separated
so i think it's going to be emotional as
well
you